[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast for
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time i'm link and i'm rhett this
week at the round table of dim lighting
we are
celebrating 10 years of good mythical
mourning it's the show that we make
other than this show it's on a platform
called youtube apparently we've been
making it on that platform for 10 years
and
last week we did a a celebration week
on the show
and we're capping that off with
a lengthy discussion a retro looking
back on the length of
good mythical morning because 10 years
link could you not use length
however we have established that your
porn name would be length neal
right
did we i don't know if we've ever said
that publicly but uh we discovered that
at some point
well how did you discover this rhett
this is weird
it was a conversation
it was a conversation amongst friends i
believe or i don't know maybe it was
you probably know it may have been on
good mythical i think it happened at
this table really length neil i think
was born at this table so um my idea
i've done some homework here
i've
looked back well let me let me just give
you my perspective on what you told me
because we were getting yeah we were
going to do a retrospective episode and
you know we actually over the summer we
did the retrospective episode of 2 000
episodes of gmm which happened over the
summer and so we're like
we're going to do the same thing so
we're trying to figure out other ways to
talk about this much gmm without dipping
back into the same conversation yeah and
it's
just a lot of conversation about fan
evolution
right and uh so
we were talking like okay we'll think
about it over break and so then when we
got back you said well um
i uh i kind of went back to the
beginning and started looking at titles
and thumbnails
just to jog my memory and then i just
went through all
all of them all 10 years worth of them
and yeah like and it took and made notes
and you were like and it took a lot
longer than i anticipated i was like
yeah it's over two i mean you could have
like i didn't realize that i was signing
myself in you could have extrapolated
and done the math length yeah and
figured out how much length this was
gonna take i felt like i really you know
i owed it to us
in
reminiscing and celebrating what we've
what we've done what we've gone through
and what we've created and and what's
evolved
i'm glad over the years i just want to
call me and say could you start from the
end and meet in the middle
you just let me uh worry about other
things well it was just fascinating
because i mean with 10 years
at a certain point the show is just it's
a staple it's a part of our lives it's
something that we
we go to the desk we enter that zone and
we
you know it's
it's
there's a rhythm to it that it can kind
of wash over you like
i'm a little self-conscious when we talk
about good mythical morning because i
know that mythical beasts when you
experience it
as a viewer it's different than how we
experience it
uh
creating it and we don't we got a point
where we don't go back and watch it
after the fact that also
many many years
we stopped doing that and i think you
probably have picked up on this as we've
talked about the show over the years
the moments don't register with us in
the same way that they register with the
audience
yeah because
um
it's i don't know it's kind of
overwhelming for us in that it's just
like what's the craziest thing you've
ever eaten what's the craziest thing
that ever happened on gm do you remember
when you did this it's like when you
point what's your favorite episode yeah
but like when i'm going to bed at night
my mind is not filled with memories of
the crazy stuff that we do on the show
um it has to sort of be like
called out so i have i have a feeling
that when you go through these things
i'm gonna be like oh man we did that
yeah we did that i would probably i
wouldn't have thought about that again
if you didn't point it out and i i was
particularly fascinated with how the
show
has evolved like remembering things that
we tried
you know because we have this
oversimplified
idea of what the show has been in
certain you know there there's a reddit
post talking about the certain eras of
good mythical morning and i think that
they presented like five
different
eras
if you go on reddit and just search gmm
eras it'll come up but yeah i ended up
going through don't search gmm errors
because that's the different we don't
want we don't want to get exposed in
that way
so
i think it would be fun for me to go
through
episode like
what's what's the word i'm looking for
notable episodes
like it's so it's not the most memorable
or the most successful episodes but it's
just notable episodes along the way that
said yeah we
we
that's part of that's part of the dna of
good mythical morning even if there's
stuff that we don't do anymore okay and
and it might jog your memory in other
ways
um
i'm also
a bit tired this morning we we we had a
little we had a party with a with with a
friend last night stayed i stayed up
past my bedtime yeah yeah 11 30. we
caught up with him at 11 30. old friend
the three of us
and it's that rarely happens well while
we were together
um
there was a point i believe it was 9 00
p.m
when
your phone well we were i was playing we
were listening to the creative house uh
but your phone at 9pm began to play a
spotify playlist that was
unbelievably soothing and that was we
were like whoa it's a hard time this is
a mood change and link was like um
this is my bedtime music
and i'm not talking about like sexual
music i'm talking about sleepy time like
make you go to sleep
bedtime music like meditation sleep
music begins for this man at 9pm and
he's only
43. when you're 73 you're gonna be
you're gonna eat at 3
30.
yeah you're going to eat at 3 30 and
you're going to go to bed at 5 00 pm
well like you know you're going to go to
bed when the sun goes there's so much
emphasis about sleep no you know like i
said last night
you analyzed our entire you're making
the healthy choice i i envy you in many
ways i'm not proud of going to bed at
life i think i get adequate sleep but i
think you get
more sleep
and i think it's probably you're going
to live longer because of it but
apparently my sleep is not of equality
oh yeah i totally forgot about it let's
save this for another episode okay let's
analyze our sleep patterns
trust me i've been through a lot of
episodes that's a good
a good idea my point was
you know we spent last night
reminiscing with an old friend and now
it's like we're continuing that two old
friends we're reminiscing about what we
could segway january 2012. it's it's
hard to believe
like i mean over the course of the week
of celebration that we just
did on good mythical morning
a lot of special moments if you haven't
seen all those episodes hey
go back it's like we were surprised by a
number of those the videos and
um
it makes me super grateful for
for what we've been through but can i
one of the things i'm seeing right now
is i actually see a video in in december
13 2011 yeah that's called you on good
mythical morning and it's us at our
desks and it's a six minute video where
we are basically i think fielding videos
for the wheel of myth for for the uh
yeah whatever we people say at the let's
talk about that we were asking people to
tell us let's talk about that so that so
it was at least a month well a month
ahead of time
we already let the audience know that
good mythical morning was coming i
didn't i haven't seen this video i've
never thought about it in 10 years and
here it is i think is it not is it
unlisted actually no
it's not unlisted
is it
not because you're logged in that might
happen
but yeah but i mean we when we started
this thing
we we've reacted on the society to the
to the first episode so i'm not going to
spend too much time on that but like the
thing that i noticed was that
my voice
this was still in a place where i was
kind of talking i was kind of talking
like this there was
and i think it was because we were
restarting something i i'd like to think
that i got into more of a rhythm with
good morning chia lincoln that i was
speaking a little more confidently
but i didn't did you go back
i didn't have the heart to go back and
see
but i will say
very quickly
as we were doing good mythical mourning
i changed so i got to a point where it's
like you know what i'm saying something
and i'm speaking at volume
but but it was
you know i'm very self-conscious of like
the what i felt like was a rough start
for me
well you know we we better to have a
rough start than a great start and then
fizzle out the reason that we both at
one point talked very quietly when we
did
podcasts was because very first podcast
we ever did was in this little office at
the
the campus crusade headquarters in apex
north carolina where we couldn't disturb
anyone else as we were talking and so we
had to be very very quiet and i think
that maybe that just stuck with you and
you forgot that there was no one around
us like when we started doing well
there's a difference when you speak at
this volume you're speaking to an
audience versus you're speaking to one
person and it's like you know you're
trying to find
you're trying to find the right zone but
you don't speak that i just wonder if
you spoke that way in regular life
because you don't speak quietly now yeah
i think there's any circumstances it's
it's more of
like developing
an on-camera persona behind that card
table right but ria i think getting like
i said we had done the rhett and link
cast the live show for over a year then
we did the chia lincoln thing and you
know i think it was more of getting
reacquainted but i'm glad that i quickly
got up to speed and then i'm also glad
that uh that we introduced puppets
actually that didn't happen until season
two
so with season one it was like we were
doing best evers
uh we also went to texas and we shot a
couple episodes you talked about talking
quietly we did like
20 worst tattoos ever which that video
performed really well we did that inside
of a tattoo yeah when we were making the
because we were still we were making
commercials
for
local businesses still we went after uh
after commercial kings
we went back to doing that what episode
was that what number
108 20 worst tattoos ever we were both
talking quietly because we were like
self-conscious
yeah i'm all if you put me in a
situation where i feel like i might be
offending someone or making someone else
feel uncomfortable that's when my
personality changes and then we do we
did take a break
to our credit we took a summer break
even after season one and we did that
thing called rhett link vault
where we're like hey we got some old
videos maybe you haven't seen them we're
gonna we're gonna contextualize them and
then you're supposed to re-watch them we
were thinking about taking breaks but
still keeping content coming
over the summer
and that i mean that was a smart move
to say this is not going to be every
single day forever
you know as we talk to other creators
now we we still very much say if there's
a way for you to set up how you work on
things so that you can
look forward to your own creative breaks
so you're not obligated
to to keep churning stuff out with with
no breaks
that's just that's a smart move right
i'm glad and also at the time
if i'm remembering this correctly
um
we had not yet developed any sort of
block shooting schedule which you know
we've we've revealed oh hell no we've
revealed the secret about that about how
we don't come in and shoot every single
day but at that time we were
so
you had you're coming in and shooting
every single day in season one so if you
didn't take a break
there was no vacation
there was nothing you know
and i definitely
remember
there were times when it's like and if
if
we would sit down to do an episode and
they were i mean they were
the the contests were very loose
and it was like okay you're gonna i
assume you're gonna bring something i'm
gonna bring something
and we're gonna try to make this thing
land around 10 minutes and we're not
going to edit it
so there's this there's a push and pull
a creative tension between the two of us
of
okay you i thought you were taking over
at this point i thought you were
bringing this perspective we had to work
through that stuff and there's no saving
it within with another camera
or or a jump cut i don't know when the
first jump cut in gmm history was
the first edit where something was
hidden
i don't but we might have didn't happen
much if any in the first in the first
season and i remember there were times
when i was like you know what i don't
feel like doing this
let's just
let's just take a walk or let's let's
not do it let's get some lunch we'll
we'll shoot two in a row tomorrow yeah
we never lost we never or we would start
it and like
one of us would be like you know what
we'd stop like five minutes in and be
like yeah this is it we're not to the
thing that we said we were actually
going to talk about let's start over
that would happen every once in a while
and then there'd be this risk of it the
other person reacting as if they were
being critiqued and
it was the dynamic there it was it was
touchy right because it was like
you both have to bring your best and
feel confident and you got to feed off
each other and if if anything goes a
little wrong
i mean we avoided as much as we could
but there were definitely times just
like okay abandon ship it's like i can
tell that you're getting frustrated with
me because i've
done something said something just wrote
you the wrong way or vice versa you know
yeah i remember that it would happen but
it was pretty rare well jason was there
at least without a third person there
like we would have been sunk because i
think those moments would have happened
even more it's like you tend to be a
little better behavior but we you know
but we were committed to the concept of
of continuing the show oh yeah so oh
yeah so we would have figured it out but
the other thing that we were we were
doing
um that i feel like is
you know
there's the
what has gotten us to this point in our
career is just this combination of good
fortune and timing and great help and
some good instincts
but
one of the things that we did is a
choice that i'm very happy that we made
is that
even though we didn't have a production
schedule per se
we weren't what most of our peers were
doing at the time
is they didn't have a they didn't have
regularly scheduled programming right
yeah so what happens is because you
don't always feel like making things and
so when you're talking about this
scenario if we were doing this
hand-to-mouth thing where we were coming
in and we were filming and then we were
posting when it was done which is pretty
much what everybody was doing at the
time and pretty much what everybody
still does in a lot of ways yeah a lot
of people still do it it gives you this
out well and then you're just there's a
fear of like if i commit to something
and then but not only that if you don't
feel like doing it you say okay guys you
go on twitter and you say guys the video
is going to be late or so sorry no video
this week
we've never done that in 10 years
that i can remember
yeah it's right it's like the season
it's like this is when the season is
it's monday through friday there's been
a couple of times where an episode
either got pulled down for some reason
or whatever and then we made another
put it on the society or i actually saw
early on in season one like a few
episodes in there was that
because of what was happening with some
internet legislation we did like a
blackout and we didn't do an episode
that day yeah but there but i think
because we didn't give ourselves that
out that's one of the reasons that 10
years later we're looking back at
21 seasons yeah season two august of
2012 that's when we introduced time
rangers
i mean those we still have the puppets
sent by mythical beasts in our
likenesses and then
so that would be within an episode but
it wouldn't be we'd talk about something
for a little bit and then we would but
we put them in the thumbnail
and there was no
this the scripting was extremely loose
for that
and i just remember that you remember
the catch phrase uh give me a second
i didn't watch any of these videos i
just
this is just come back to me we would
say it we would say it together
yeah we were horrible at puppeteering it
was our version of like to infinity and
beyond or something
to the time it was like something about
the time machine to the gazebo to the
gazebo the gazebo was the gazebo was the
time machine
and i think time rangers
everybody just been a mispronunciation
of time rangers in the first episode i
don't know well based on the thumbnails
and the the associated view counts
puppets not a strong choice we did best
ever fridays
wow people hated habits
people hate puppets uh episode 37 how to
make someone sound like an idiot
so
th this was this was an early important
episode for us because
we talked about like the darwin awards
and and there were
so we talked about
the thing that won and then we talked
about another thing and then we talked
about the speech jammer
device that you've appointed at somebody
it's in the thumbnail but like we we
said hey we can do this ourselves using
the delay within garageband
and you listen to yourself talking on a
delay
and you sound like an idiot
and that was absolutely hilarious but we
waited until
i don't know seven eight minutes into
the episode the episode was over before
we actually began demonstrating it
because the first half of the episode we
were talking about the
these those inventions right
and and
like the research side of things
and
we've told the story at some point i'm
sure but uh
a good friend and manager of ours at the
time was
we were talking about that episode and
he was like hey um and this was this was
actually like a year after the fact yeah
this is dan we we were talking about
kind of making some
like we were evaluating gmm and he was
like you know yes like we said we wanted
to put sponsors in we had sponsors a
slot for sponsors from the beginning but
we were like
well we need to be making more money
doing this thing so like that's why we
were having these conversations with dan
and he said you know my favorite episode
is that is the speech jammer episode and
i send it to people but i always have to
when i send it to people i say
fast forward to like you know seven or
eight minutes in when they start doing
this right and then it
was like well why don't we make the
episode about one thing
which was
typically what we did but we were it was
sort of a reevaluation of what we were
doing it's like if people are clicking
on this because of
this expectation we want to deliver on
that expectation and that was pretty we
were it was a pretty significant mind
shift for us yeah and we i think there
was a little bit of fear in it because
we were playing an episode we'd be like
we got to make sure that we can fill the
time what if you know
in real time so we're going to save this
thing that we know is going to be funny
for a little bit later so that the
episode is full we didn't have enough
confidence that like okay you take one
thing that people want to click on and
then you flesh it out it's like now we
got to throw other things in
first to make sure that we can
we can break 10 minutes
and once we made that shift and said you
know no you have a good concept you lead
with it and you flesh it out
that that certainly helped the product
drastically i mean one of the things i'm
noticing is just looking at these old
thumbnails and the associated
views is
there's an incredible range
of how low it can be and how high it can
be right there's yeah there's a
psychopath smell test where we're
wearing blindfolds episode 38 which has
got 5.8 million views from nine years
ago and then you know there's the puppet
episode right next to it well over the
years people have gone before right it's
just and cherry picked ones that i think
resonate more with where the show ended
up going well i feel like
psychologically i feel like i can
actually look at these thumbnails
without the the view counts and be
pretty accurately predict which ones
perform well now that
10 years of all this data of how people
respond to titles and thumbnails it was
just so experimental at the time
we had and the feedback we're looking at
10 years of collective feedback on these
videos 9 or 10 years yeah
and so you see this like cumulative
effect of like
no one cares about gladiators versus
puppets to the tune of 273 000 views
you know next to a six million view
video it's just and then we wrap up
season two
with episode 86 which was a christmas
special
so oh yeah you know even though it was
our it was the first year of the show it
was not it was still a side project in a
lot of ways
it's like we gotta let's do something i
mean we're not we're gonna take a
holiday break let's do a special and we
threw all this stuff at it julian smith
was in that got 575 000 views which is
pretty low for that for that time which
again it was and it was a lot of work it
was how long 28 minutes
um
but it was special i i think that it the
decision to make that special
and make it 28 minutes and make it a
variety show was what led directly to
the mythical musical show you're exactly
right
because that's why we decided to do the
myth totally on our own we had just we
had done this and it was like well if we
can do it we can do it again and we and
and people liked it
i'm gonna put my phone on non-buzz
let's do an ad
non-buzz you know something else people
like
getting stuff from our store we really
appreciate that we have a lot of stuff
over at mythical.com for sale
but it's a rotating but again
i mean people people like it they like
the stuff that's happening our team is
creating incredible merchandise and
people are buying it it goes away and
also we like to keep it fresh i mean
this isn't like your grandma's house
where you're going to show up and she's
going to make exactly the same fried
chicken or country-style steak
we're not your grandma right okay we got
things we don't change but the thing we
do change is we change the merch we love
your grandma we know we could never be
your grandma that's why we change things
up but if you but if you're like okay i
understand your philosophy
well the but i but i don't want to miss
out on anything well that's why we
created the last chance section yeah
it's your last chance to go get
something that's never going to come
back and we put it in a section tell
your grandma about it so you can go
there
season three uh well january 2013
episode 13 do you remember we tried
something called musicals yes
where we would take a story we had taken
funny
news stories
like somebody getting arrested over like
complaining about their fries at
mcdonald's and stuff like that
and we would we would use those news
stories just for conversation but then
we were like let's let's toy with a
format let's actually sing these things
to some like royalty-free music sure it
wasn't like we would guitar we played no
and
it was so it was a kind of operatic
talky singy type thing yeah it was fun
everybody liked it
but it didn't really
work but it just goes to show you
i mean from an early point we were like
trying to
develop formats well it and again when
you look at okay so episode 13 pizza
thief the musical just get the picture
of you holding
a pizza and singing 464 000 views the
next day episode 14 nutella versus
peanut butter taste test 1.8 million
views now again at the time it wasn't
like we were getting this incredible
feedback it wasn't like it no the way
right you know this is quite an
operation at this point we we we do a b
testing on titles and thumbnails that's
why they change early in the day you
know and and we've it's become much more
of a science at the time it was more of
an art it was throwing things out onto
the internet and also i would say a week
after that episode goes up
we weren't we weren't learning hey
people are loving the nutella versus
peanut butter taste test this view
discrepancy is something that is
registering
over the course of a decade right not
the course of us then making decisions
about our content i mean i will say six
episodes later walmart brand versus name
brand taste test and then episode 29
rhett and link eat insects which still
hasn't broken a million views which is
interesting which in the walmart brand
versus brand name taste test has got
almost 7 million views which i you know
and again we we talk about this uh quite
a bit but it just kind of illustrates
this thing that there's this um what we
don't do what we try not to do is just
follow it's just oh people like this and
so that's what we're that's the only
thing that we're going to make but it
does get so we still have to do some
stuff that's just for us and for the the
folks who have been around forever right
so i'm not saying we wouldn't do another
musical it's just now it's ten years
later there's this mentality that like
okay if we're gonna do a musical episode
we already know it's gonna be a lot of
work a lot of fun it's going to be very
rewarding for us and the people who
watch
but it's not going to make any money and
no one's going to watch it and you just
have to be like and that's okay and
we're going to go we're going to go for
it you know that's what looking back on
this is sort of the sort of just a
reminder of the way this system works
and you know we were still sharing
personal stories
i mean our experiences of getting
acclimated we're living
full-time in los angeles having moved
across country
uh
our kids our wives
making the transition we would share
funny stories but even over the course
of season two that started to diminish
more because running out of stuff
because we knew that like our personal
stories couldn't couldn't support an
entire show forever yeah
right um
so it's not like we're now doing that on
another show that's even longer episode
31 rhett and link are moving
episode 32 new studio tour
so
by that point
the beginning of
season three in 2013 is when we moved
into the new studio
we we knew at that point we were making
the mythical show because that's what
gave us the confidence to start renting
a space
and the necessity to rent a space
because we were hiring people yeah hired
stevie we hired ben we hired jen
um
and we moved into that new studio
uh
episode 32 and we kept me and then
we had a makeshift they were building
the set downstairs which ultimately
became the good mythical morning set but
it was built as the mythical show set
and then upstairs we would just set up
the card table and
working with jason we would still make
good mythical mourning while everybody
that we were hiring
was working towards the mythical show
was that whole season on uh in that
space was these all of season three in
that upstairs space at the whole studio
from episode 32 to episode 60. so and
when we were up there
in that space our energy started to be
um
diverted into preparati preparating for
the mythical show
so it's like what we couldn't prepare as
much for an episode so i remember
telling jason like this is a problem
episode 35 best movie theme songs but
instead of us
alternating and saying what we think are
the best movie theme songs
we turn it into a game
i'm not saying this was the first game
we ever played
but it it could have been but it was in
this era that we started to gamify
things because it took the pressure off
of us to prepare a lot when we had to
devote that type of energy to the
mythical show yeah that's a good point
episode 46 most amazing optical
illusions got 22 million views but
episode 55 and 56 were both games
cartoon theme songs games greatest april
fool's
game
you know where one of us would quiz the
other or jason would quiz both of us and
it was yeah it was the games kind of
came out it was accessibility efficiency
thing it was it was like
yeah again i'm gonna digest all this
information and have to spit it back out
or just perform and react but it wasn't
that we were thinking you know games
will be fun it was like no we need
we need something that takes the
pressure off
games can do that
it it moves the the prep the writing if
you will it it kind of started to
convince us
because jason was an editor
and maybe he would have done some
research but we never
allowed ourselves to think that like we
could ever hire
writers
but then you're like hey jason we didn't
write this game we didn't think of and
all of a sudden we have a writer we just
didn't know it we didn't think of the
show as a show that needed
writing
because when we thought about writing we
thought about scripted
stuff
exactly in fact that's still often a
misconception when people find out that
there's writers for good mythical
mourning they interpret that as so what
you're saying is scripted
just know what we're doing
what we're learning about the game that
we're playing the question that was
being asked that's scripture yeah the
name of the game on the title screen
yeah you know
there's so many details there's so much
to be written when you actually start
thinking about it but but yeah as
creators it's like it's one thing to
start and trust someone else to edit you
that's a journey a lot of creators
get hung up on but then moving to a
point where you get somebody to write
for you
it's like oh you can think of it
differently it's not
it's not putting words in somebody's
mouth necessarily so all of that up into
episode 60 was leading up to the
mythical show
which was 12 episodes
and even now looking back at the
mythical show i'm very
i haven't
watched it a long time
but um
i'm sure it's i'm sure i'm i'd be proud
of it and it's it i'd be very endeared
by it and i'm sure there's a lot of
things
you know embedded in these half hours
that
we carried forward oh yeah creatively i
i would have to sit down and watch them
all i'm sure people could point that out
but only two of the 12 to this day have
broken a million views again it's just
that the longer thing is not what 10 of
them
and it you know that was youtube giving
us a chunk of money to hire people to
make this show to experiment with longer
format
and then you know it's it there's
parallels between that and when we when
we did the expanded version of gmm that
comes later gmm-22 that like okay even
though it didn't work
there was an infusion of create like
trying so many things at such an
increased rate
and figuring out how to work with a team
that is growing in the process
is is something that then has rep ripple
effects because
we kept stevie on and then it was like
okay good mother we're going back to
good mythical morning and it needs to be
part of your focus good mother the
mythical show which was your focus is
going away but i i kind of
i remember the mindset
going into the mythical show at least as
i was thinking
i was very excited about the mythical
show
and
i think there was a big part of me that
was thinking if this works
this could be what we do instead of good
mythical morning oh yeah right because
again i i was more excited about we
didn't we there was no plan to go back
to good mythical morning that i can
recall i was super excited about this
this high level of this
there's so much creativity just put into
one particular episode and there's a
music video and there's a sketch and
then there's a game so it's a little bit
of everything that we could do
but pretty early on it became clear that
like wow
again there's this weird thing the the
feedback that we're getting
not and i'm not talking about the
quality of the feedback i'm talking
about the quantity of the feedback like
some people
who are who who are
who love what we we do and love all the
creativity are like so excited about
something like the mythical show but you
can't like we couldn't have kept like we
couldn't have first of all youtube
wasn't going to give us any more money
for that
but even the money they gave us to do
that show wasn't sustainable like the
business would have just like completely
gone under if we were like let's just
keep making that show with that money
that we're getting from youtube like it
wasn't a sustainable business model but
there was a little bit of this
ah man we put this thing out there that
felt like it was
creatively innovative and
uh okay well i guess we'll we'll go back
to talking to each other at a desk every
single day there was to me there was a
little bit of like ah really okay okay
that this is this is what you want from
us you don't want us to do this
incredibly
creative stuff
but also the thing that was happening
and listen i don't wanna i've [ __ ] my
mind has shifted a lot over the years on
this because
i didn't appreciate
at this stage eight years ago i still
had not accepted the fact that
this medium
was very different than traditional
media in that it was much more about
connecting
with people and one of the things that
people were
appreciating was not that we could write
a great song or
you know do something funny as a sketch
it was that they're like i like being
with those guys and being a part of
their friendship and seeing them crack
each other up and seeing them laugh and
yeah that was the experience that was
comforting people and entertaining
people
and it's just a mind shift it doesn't
mean that we don't do
have all these creative aspirations it's
just now we kind of understand that
there's a certain place for those that's
probably not going to be
a half hour youtube video on the good
mythical morning channel
um but this was the that was the first
sort of like throwing this thing out
there thinking that maybe this will
change everything maybe we'll have the
first ever really popular half hour
comedy show it'll go it'll be like the
carol barnette show but it'll be on
youtube and it'll go for 10 years no
that's not what happened so we went back
in fall of 2013
leading up to season four
of good mythical morning
we made that weekend sucks ad
you know
when when good mythical morning is not
around the weekend suck
uh episode one
which is the 275th episode overall we
had we were on the new set we had
altered the good the mythical show set
to be the good mythical morning set
we started saying let's talk about that
and we moved the the wheel
the the fan videos to be for the wheel
spin the wheel that was all part of a a
really focused
evaluation that involved stevie yeah of
like okay we're changing the way we're
producing it we're applying this team
but i was also when stevie began to
she turned her attention
where she had she had not really been
involved at all creatively with gmm that
after the mythical show she turned her
creative instincts and producer
instincts on to to gmm and so the three
of us were sort of attacking this thing
and we had we we had a few writers at
the time yeah yeah and we we kept
our writers on board um
actually
that's not true we didn't we didn't have
any writers yet besides
hmm
i'm pretty sure we didn't
because this was also when we started we
started good mythical more
with season three but it was on our
website so we were still doing it
started at season three but we had it at
rentlink.com yep we were we're trying to
get people to go to our website and
that's the only way you could watch good
mythical more
episode four was a spicy pepper
challenge
and ben stevie and jason and jen all
came on during good mythical more and i
was like this is the whole team bonding
experience where we're we we impromptu
brought them on camera and made them eat
the
the peppers yeah
and so it was just kind of like
something that happened
and that's why i think that was the
extent of our team at the beginning of
season three
episode 27
six legal things that should be illegal
so this is we were doing these list
episodes like okay if buzzfeed can do
all these click baity stuff and there's
all these clickbaity
listicle titles out there
all over the internet
we're basically capitalizing on that
yeah and we were and we was really
working you got eight million views for
six legal things that should be illegal
i just can't i can't resist clicking on
that it's like no one gives a [ __ ] about
that now it's like you know it's so yeah
i mean we learned that over time this is
why that's why those lists went away
everyone learned every list
yeah it's like every one of them
everyone was like i've been i've been
through every list there's no more lists
yeah they were click baited so much
that's like you know it's i was burned
one too many times with a list that
didn't come through and the thumbnail
strategy at this point i'm noticing with
that episode it just has a like a stock
photo of a woman sneezing into blackness
i do what i don't that was a good
thumbnail because i don't see your face
going
no or my face going
no i don't see that um yeah it was like
this i remember i would work closely
with jason to like figure out some sort
of eye-catching photoshop thing that was
like okay here's a sneeze
there was a completely isolated
self-contained
strategy for every single thumbnail as
opposed to a thumbnail strategy yeah
which is but that's exhausting that's a
function of what youtube has changed we
also started ear biscuits
episode 25 we announced ear biscuits on
season four and we started doing
saturday ear biscuit promos
we put a video up on saturday where we
would talk about the ear biscuit because
there was no video and we would tell a
story but it wasn't a clip it was it was
related to the ear biscuit that you
could go and listen to yeah so like we
talked i forgot all about this like yeah
in october we had defranco on the show
and we were talking about that and he
talked about a friend of his and so then
on our sunday episode we spent a few
minutes talking about ben
back then in 2013.
you know what ended up being an entire
episode that like is the most viewed on
the your biscuits
youtube channel yeah by a long shot um
yeah i just i totally forgot that we did
that
episode 36 is when we did the hashtag
war
hashtag one of my favorite things
hashtag gmmm we took it from good good
morning memphis and good good morning
maryland good morning maryland two
morning shows like two morning new shows
that were using the hashtag gmm
and we basically did a full-on
coordinated assault to try to
uh
claim gmm for ourselves but the it was
obviously a publicity stunt and we it
did end up getting featured at least on
good morning memphis i think that good
morning maryland at the time like did
somebody didn't follow through they were
a little cold towards the idea we made
some jingles for them but i don't i'm
glad you brought this up because i was
actually thinking about this
this morning
that there is
there is a there is a gmm out there that
is
really popular now
i've talked i told you a little bit
about this
uh it seems to be more popular though oh
yeah you're talking about a new hashtag
yeah if you just put gmm on twitter
um put gmm on twitter wait it sounds
like such a dad look younger gmm
actresses there is a
show
uh gmm 25 thailand is tweeting about
this
i don't know where the show is i don't
know what country this show is in
but it is incredibly popular and there's
like a there's a huge cast
of characters oh it's that are on this
gmm
show
and
we have to do something i mean i don't
think we can take the the hashtag back
but i feel like a collaboration is at
least in order again i i'd have no idea
what the show is i don't have
endorse it i don't know anything about
it so just let me be clear about that
but i just it's not a band
no it's a show gmm actresses
it's just it's a show i'm 100 sure that
it's the show
but there's a there's a there's all
kinds of people associated with it this
is i mean this is an after party a gmm
after party
we weren't there oh yeah it has nothing
to do with us
that must be fixed
like we should we need to be involved
look see here's this clip from the show
right here i swear if gmm won't give us
another due to
oh i still blame time for ringoria not
in-game
gmm got no manager to drive is it
what
no we're going to figure this out we'll
figure that out
in the meantime i'm going to continue my
stroll down memphis you know
more about gmm the other gmm and you're
a fan
hashtag your biscuits ironically not
hashtag gmm
no so rounding out that fall of 2013
um
episode 76 never wet our pants
17 million views i'll never wet our
pants yeah episode 79 13 million views
when we we got waxed
we got we got waxed
so i mean we're starting to get some
momentum here season five
um
january of 2014
that's when we moved good mythical more
to youtube so the the putting it on
ratling.com was a short-lived experience
yeah that didn't that that didn't last
episode 18
that's when we exotic meat taste test
that's when we broke a million
subscribers well one of the things that
i'm seeing in the numbers here
is that
season five so they're seeing like
towards the end of season four
okay this we're getting
some stuff is really taking off some
some stuff is really getting traction
season five
so seven years ago yeah that's when that
that has to be based on the numbers that
i'm seeing that has to be the beginning
of what we called the youtube algorithm
change that we benefited from where they
started rewarding
watch time yeah doesn't that sound about
like the beginning of that seven years
ago so like 2015 yeah because we got a
we got a million view
a million subscribers around that time
and then
at the end of 2015 we were abr about to
break 10 million subscribers
so for the next
at the end of 2015 yeah at the end of
2015.
went so we went from 1 million so that
was like a course of a year man
how's that possible no it was 24 two
years
so over those two years still that's the
january 2014 we had a million subs
january 20
yeah january 2016
is when we had 10 million subscribers
so yeah that's when it really started to
pick up
uh i mean i remember the thing that i
was thinking at this time
is that
i had always seen gmm as
what i called the side project right i
mean that's why we put it on the second
channel yeah uh the same this at this
time we're still doing like sketches
music videos and that kind of thing
but
this
we all this was the year that that two
year period 2014 to 2015 is where
gmm
surpassed in anything that we were doing
on the rhett and link channel on the
main channel in terms of just the level
of engagement and the number at least
the number of subscribers and just the
fan base that was building around it
yeah and it was and i think both of us
were thinking like oh man this is this
is becoming our thing this isn't this is
not a side project yeah so a lot more
focus so much so that we were like let's
make a hawkman trailer for a hawkman
movie that doesn't exist
in hopes that like people will care
about that they didn't really they did
that episode 82
will it taco
episode 88 sensory deprivation tank
so it's like we we had just hatched the
willett series
and
you know the sensory deprivation tank
was
okay we're going to go out into the
world and do some stuff we didn't do it
that often but it was
really good well before moving past
willa taco she's got 20 million views
now
um
was this the up until this point
i don't know if we had done like the
next time we did willa after this was
when because up to this point we didn't
see things as series
yeah right i don't see any evidence it
was always like kind of okay maybe this
is a slight twist on something that we
did or we're playing a game but we
didn't
have a title
that just changed out one word like will
it taco oh now let's do will it burrito
or whatever and jill so that was cinco
de mayo in july we did will it ice cream
sandwich that which was uh in the next
season six okay so it took us a full
season
to come back to
that's interesting again we weren't
seeing like uh it took us two months
yeah but we weren't and we're just way
different these days where
uh
we're constantly trying to come up with
an idea that then can be a series
because we just found that that's what
people like i mean obviously there's
production um considerations for that
you get something that works you want to
do it again because the team knows how
to produce that but also like p it
develops a life of its own like the
international dark game has at this
point which i'm sure you'll talk about
the first time we did that eventually
but we had we weren't thinking about the
show in that way
at this time yeah at the end
over the course of season five the other
thing we did was uh wheeling mythicality
animations we started releasing those
and then season six july of 2014 that's
when we got our new intro with the the
column where it starts at night and like
it's going up the column
um
we still had some more animations coming
out
episode nine of season six that's when
we did the va vacay gone cray-kay
cray-kay crank it cray-cray
where we would reenact
um
stories of people's vacations gone wrong
which was sponsored by the same people
that sponsored
uh
i'm on vacation the music video
it's like ho ho some of the hotels
choice hotels yeah but yeah in that
episode
nine
it was also on a thursday that's when we
would also do mail so we started having
variety episodes
where we would do it we'd do a little
something
usually usually
have a prompt from a fan and then we
would go into a the vacay gone cray-cray
segment because we wanted to be able to
sell to a sponsor
a segment within an episode but then do
other things that we could use to market
the episode with
title and thumbnail
and we would add mail to it
and then so jen would bring out the mail
but she wasn't on camera and it was in
the main episode she wasn't on camera
she wasn't on camera
uh we did and we did sing the song
yes thursday means mail that and you're
talking season six yeah
episode nine episode nine episode 17
okay because we still called that
outrageous camping gear you must own and
yeah because the first thing we talked
about was which got 5.6 million
outrageous camping gear
again the lists were working for us no
one was going to click on watch us
reenact
somebody's bad vacation
but once we got to click with the crazy
looking tents
so we were figuring out those things
it's like
if we can do a variety episode every
week
we can learn more we can do more
creative things and we can you know we
can connect with the mythical beast by
like reading their mail
episode 17
is when we went to the youtube
space and we had daniel radcliffe on the
show up until this point we really
hadn't had guests on the show we had had
guests on
appear
on the mythical show but then
we didn't add any guests when we went
back to good mythical morning
but we couldn't turn down daniel
radcliffe and i just remember being so
freaking nervous like i still can't i
wouldn't watch that episode back well
we
wanted it to we first of all
we had this hang up and we still do have
it
uh where we were like
okay
when
a celebrity comes to the youtube space
and other youtubers go to it it's almost
like a press junket and they're just
making videos
it for us it felt a little cheap right
because we were like man we want our
show to feel like a place that
celebrities want to come and actually be
on because that's what a legitimate show
is jimmy fallon doesn't go and yeah go
somewhere he said you come to a show
that had never happened but we said
that's how we would want it to happen
but the compromise was
we're going to print out
our set uh no paisley actually built it
he built it like uh oh yeah
it was like yes paper mosaic yes it was
really amazing what he did
and i don't even think it came across on
camera but you your eyes forget that
we're not in front of our own set yeah
so we did a basically a portable set
which was a whole lot of work later when
we had to do the same thing
another time we played it out yeah yeah
i forgot the first one was like literal
he unrolled the thing unrolled yeah it's
crazy and then we had to sit around for
hours for dana rachel to show up
and he was a joy he was a joke it was a
joy episode 56
that was the carolina reaper that's
still the thing that is more often than
anything the thing that people talk
about if they if they see us on the
street episode 110 was our first
weirdest ebay we're stevie oh really the
host
well okay so steve yeah wrapping up 2014
point did stevie start becoming the
voice of the goddess
off off camera um
i don't know
because i know that season 4 episode 64
where we did the movie setting game
which was the first time that we had we
like
we're like let's put a title screen on
this we still didn't say it's time for
but we called it something impromptu and
like jason made a title screen jason was
the off-screen
voice
for those games so i don't know exactly
when that switch but by this point
stevie was not only she was she did that
on camera what was doing stuff off
camera i'm sure by that point
so then let's go to season seven all
right january 2015
uh we had a new wheel
with 24 spaces
yeah that was a big moment
i think we would have variety episodes
that were they were they were they were
still question based
so i remember that we would we would
take questions from mythical beasts and
we would use those the writers would
then pitch us comedy bits to do
like someone was someone gave feedback
on how i was
like we took a comment about how i made
eddie eat something that he didn't want
to eat and i was kind of being a jerk to
him and so they were like they were like
you were like yeah it actually happens a
lot we cut to a sketch
of hidden camera footage of me being a
tyrant around the studio so we were
still trying all different types of
things in like these mini varieties five
million views before it does
it does at this point because we called
it link is a tyrant
we also started song biscuits
so this was a new thing it's like all
right let's not just doing an ear
biscuit and having them come on the show
but that was a weekend series yeah but
we got
i mean that was ambitious that was kind
of a hey you're going to come on a
podcast and then you're going to write a
song with us
i wouldn't have said yes to that uh we
made it easy for people man they didn't
yeah but i was like man that was
asking a lot of people uh okay but so
yeah and like you said before that there
was the the wheel of mythicality
animations again so
i'm thinking about where this decision
leads that's one of the fascinating
things for me is yeah we make a decision
for whatever reason we were making it at
the time and
then just making the decision then leads
to something else so i would say that
decisions like this to do song biscuits
on the weekend
okay did it maybe what we were thinking
i know one of the things we were
thinking was
man like we spent we've gotten to this
point where we're putting so much time
into good mythical morning
it doesn't really justify itself to put
all this time into a music video
on our main channel unless it's
sponsored uh
and even then sometimes it would be
weeks or months of work for one piece of
content right whereas we can't do as
well with gmm
so we were like okay well we're still
really good at writing songs let's make
it something that's more interactive and
and quicker and that's what led to doing
some biscuits and hey why not why didn't
we put that on the rhett and link
channel well again at this point in
season seven there's all this traction
on good mythical morning so it's like
this is the place that people's eyeballs
are so let's put it on the weekend on
the orbit on the gmm channel
that decision
led to
things like mythical kitchen right
because mythical kitchen developing
kitchen it was a weekend show
you know where josh would make something
on the weekend i don't know how long
that went yeah i can get into some of
that but yeah for this and it was also
we're trying to promote this podcast
through
yeah right our channel that's because it
was still ep it was still guest-based
ear biscuits was guest-based at the time
2015 we go into the fall for season
eight
we were done with song biscuits
and we started them releasing the
animated versions of those as a music
video
um the backup plan continued we did the
cereal bowl bath on episode five we
really weren't having a lot of guests
but episode 55 was when we had shea
mitchell come on
because
there was there was some sort of
connection that like
she actually wanted to come on our show
and i had to eat it i ate a live beetle
i'm not proud of that well and we had
episode 45 we had smosh
on the on the show yeah so we
started to anthony at the time i think
we had them on ear biscuits and that was
like a cross promotion instead of doing
a song biscuit
because i guess we were done with those
it's like maybe we can double up and
we'd already we had already gone to
pirates versus ninjas for debatarama
yeah that that that was the beginning of
the end for the debates yeah if i recall
it didn't work that well episode 91 we
did will it pie which is the only will
it on location yeah out in front of the
pie hole
nobody really cared that it was
interesting but it wasn't anything to
continue it didn't add anything no
didn't add anything so then which i
think is an important point to register
because this is like oh well this
episode required traveling to a place
setting up uh and it's like oh this will
be cool breath of fresh air literally
but also
makes the show feel like it's it could
go anywhere yeah and you're like oh it
didn't translate into anything else we
could have just been at the desk let's
just be at the desk january 2016 season
nine
that's when we got in that new uh desert
intro
and it was my new haircut
2016. wow it's been that long it's been
that long willets were still the biggest
thing but we were doing games we were
doing ranking stuff we were still doing
lists
um
episode 43 can you hear colors
so we're doing experiments
i mean we were we were trying a bunch of
different taste test stuff like the
flavored oxygen taste test
physical challenges like we were doing
these weird
like we would invent our own physical
challenges and that like magnetized
mullets
magnified mazes like all these weird
physical challenges
um
that didn't last too long
uh but episode 62
i think is still our most viewed video
ever game show cheaters amazing game
show cheaters which was just an anomaly
that thing blew up
way after the fact something happened
something happened with the youtube
system
that kept sending this video as a
suggested video it was a you can see
where the views came from and it was
always a suggested video that was
popping up for people and people want to
click on that and they just like i was a
cheater during the showcase showdown
yeah we put a we you know we put an
arrow at the cheater we had an extras
channel that we were doing good mythical
crew but then we moved that show good
mythical crew to saturdays
it's where we would have like mike or
alex or chase
uh
like showing them how they would
what now is behind the mythicality on
the mythical society basically
is something that we started in 2016.
and it was starting to feature the crew
and show behind the scenes content but
also there was you sort of skipped over
the middle thing because that was again
it was a saturday launch
for something that then became its own
channel it for
for a certain it was there was an extras
channel and then
we were it wasn't called this is
mythical yet and we were moving some so
that was the main thing the good
mythical crew right yeah this is when we
broke 10 million subscribers
uh and had our 900th episode
um
episode 105
will it burger that was the first job
this mythical chef josh appearance when
we broke 10 million because yeah earlier
you said we broke 10 million at the end
of 2015. yeah it was episode 70 so at
the beginning of 2016. okay so it was it
was still like basically two years two
years almost two years exactly
um
so then josh showed up but then he went
away again for like a a while he only
helped us in that one episode
and then episode 120 that's when we
announced buddy system season one so
like all of this stuff was happening
back then
around this time season nine going into
season 10.
season 10
episode 54
we released buddy system we did the
conjoined twin challenge
and we we celebrated our the 1000th
episode we also did our it looks like
our first ever retrospective episodes
around the holidays right very different
thumbnail
strategy like top 10 link gags
ridiculous rhett reactions
retin link can't stop laughing they were
shorter
but this was sort of the precursor to
what we do now which is like the top
five moments yeah we ended that right
before we did those retrospectives we
released episode 102
which was the international christmas
food
so we we were we were throwing darts at
the end of 2016. so the very very
beginning the first time we did that we
were already throwing darts all right so
now we're in january 2017 for season 11.
this is when we had this is mythical
channel okay throwing things over there
but we were still doing the good
mythical crew
episodes
i think on saturday on on gmm but
um we weren't having guests unless we
had a connection to them like mayam on
what's on my head for episode 33. i was
the human nacho in episode 65 episode 69
that became a thing yeah that became a
discontinued snack taste test
started back then in episode 69
and then
after around episode 83 is when we
announced buddy system season two
and that's when we started doing good
mythical summer for the first time yeah
so a couple of things were happening
there so with buddy system going into
season two at this point
uh again we were putting it on the good
mythical morning channel even though we
didn't want to uh and that was just
because by that time again we were
there's so much focus on gmm and it's so
difficult to like keep this level of
content up and also make a scripted show
do the podcast do the weekend series
that it was like okay there's not a lot
happening on the main channel it's not
now we just call it rhett and link
channel
because it's definitely not the main
channel
so yeah it was like this is a little bit
weird to put this on
gmm but
it probably will get more views i don't
know if that was true if it yeah it
would have gotten more views if we put
it on the rent link channel but we had
to announce it during this season so we
could explain why we were doing good
mythical summer and we were having guest
hosts it's like why are you guys going
away what is it you're doing so we would
start teasing it but then it wasn't
until season 12 that fall
when it actually started coming out
a lot of things
happened in season 12. i mean we had our
new stop-motion animation episode three
was our brosecomies oh wow
we released our book of mythicality in
episode 37 and announced a tour
for that
episode 44 is that was our first leaving
things in coke
episode 52 was our last episode before
we switched over to gman 22 in the
middle of the season
wow so there was so much stuff happening
at this point i'm thinking about i'm
trying to like
think beyond just what was so much
happening with good mythical morning
yeah um
it was now i mean just getting
vasectomies would have been enough for
that now one thing i will say by season
12 which was what year 2017 so 2017 like
if you go in the back end and you look
at
the engagement and the views and all
that stuff so again there was this sort
of incredible
time of like 2014 2015 2016 like this
three-year period
in which there was this incredible
amount of views an incredible amount of
audience growth like you said like
breaking 10 million subscribers
2017
sort of represented a little bit of a
slo things were beginning to slow down
now this wasn't well i would say level
out
yeah yeah you know well the growth was
the growth was slowing down like this
explosive growth was slowing down and
then if you just look at the numbers
what you'll what you won't see
is you won't see an episode that has 12
15 18 20 million views like some of
those ones that had broken out during
that time now again that's not a
function of a strategy change on our
part it's just it's a chain it's a
function of the change of audience taste
and also the youtube platform so we so
we're kind of like okay this is maybe
the new normal for where this thing is
shaking out in the meantime doing all
this other stuff like you mentioned the
book the tour the show
and then youtube knocks on our door and
says hey do you want to
they actually said do you want to do a
good mythical night or good mythical
evening
like a
a night a daily nightly show in addition
to your daily show we were like do you i
mean there's only two of us we have a
lot of help but there's still only two
these two guys that turned into well
let's let's apply those changes to good
mythical morning itself and hence gmm
22. we call it 22 because it was
you know a half hour of television is
actually just 22 minutes of content so
we were trying to make four videos that
totaled up to roughly 22 minutes of
content because there was a little bit
of a potential
hope and actually this was discussed is
would maybe that show in its entirety
end up on linear television at some
point like that was there was discussion
about that i mean it was crazy that that
was a discussion but that was a
discussion most of the discussions were
about click the green border yeah yeah
we're not going to talk negatively about
gm mm-22 yeah i'm not good enough i'll
present the positive sides of it you
know this was the first like we
accelerated like how big our team was
how big our set was
all
there was an injection of creativity
that where we had to make all these
different videos we had to make four
videos a day instead of one so we were
willing to try things and say okay one
of these or two of these segments are
going to be the things you expect and
they're going to perform well like
episode
59
freezing our bodies this is going to
work we're going to go to a cryogenic
therapy place then we're going to come
back to the set and do big mac versus
whopper
and that's going to perform really well
and then we're going to do this
silly invention thing where
we
we wear sauna pants which we just made
and then we're going to do this very
quick
thing called censored kissing game which
the writers
really had to push the writers to to
come up with comedy bits that then
we could where we could play fun games
or are quick improv type things
so we were
we were reapplying
our efforts and lessons from way back
with this is uh the mythical show
which was a half hour and saying
well yeah we're not going to make a 30
minute video we're going to make each of
these internet videos and then
there's room for experimentation and
because of that
we did
learn a lot but we had to do things like
we have to have a teleprompter yeah this
was the beginning this is this is when
we started having a teleprompter instead
of like trying to commit stuff to memory
for just a few seconds and then say it
in twice as much time as
it it needs to take and to claim with a
lot more prep than we have time to give
to it and to clarify okay so when we
talk about what scripted and what's not
scripted on good mythical morning so for
a very very long time
maybe not from the very beginning but
definitely their early seasons
what we had scripted was okay at the
beginning of this thing when the camera
turns on and we say good mythical
morning the things that we're going to
say right at the top are essentially
scripted it started loose and it was
like okay i've got a little thing i'm
going to say and then you're like
i'm going to react to it
then it slowly evolved to a place where
it was i think literally written down
and we would look at it and be like okay
i think i can
i think i can say that again this is
just the intro just like the first
minute or so of the show
to kind of because we wanted to quickly
and efficiently get into the good stuff
and set it up in the right way orient
people maybe there were rules or
whatever
so
yeah so that was that was the existing
system and then but what would happen
sometimes is we would have this sheet of
paper and we'd be trying to get it and
we'd go through two three four takes
sometimes just getting the takeoff of
the show done which is very frustrating
and it's it's taking a bunch of time and
and i think
all along
i can't remember who it was if it was
stevie or whoever it was was like what
about a teleprompter we were very
anti-teleprompter because
if you know what it looks like when
somebody's reading a teleprompter you
know what it looks like when somebody's
reading a teleprompter right yeah
and then that makes it feel the show
feel less authentic and plus
we were self-conscious about it but we
basically knew we had to to figure it
out we had to utilize it for the show
openings and
so it was just one of those things that
made
gmm 22 feel off at the beginning it
wasn't just about the fact that it was
the wrong color
and that we're using different cameras
there was a lot of transitions that
shouldn't have impacted the audience
experience that did because it was a
there were so many things that we were
changing in our experience behind the
scenes so like using a teleprompter
and the specifics of how we were using
it um and but that ended up being a good
thing it's like forcing us to figure out
what are our terms for using this tool
we use we learn when not to use it
because i think we over did it in
certain times and we also got better at
you know if you want to look and you
want to follow our eyes and get really
specific you i mean you you probably if
you watch the show enough you know when
it's happening
but we got better at it so somebody
who's coming into the show for the first
time doesn't feel like i'm walking into
this stiff newscaster situation we also
had like writers writing more comedy
bits that like we were figuring out is
this for us are we
do we want do we enjoy this are we good
at it can we take someone else's joke
and say it as our own there's a lot of
and
or work within an improv bit where it's
like
we're gonna
you know we're gonna be sucking helium
and saying
and then ranting about things that are
again on a teleprompter
and a lot of things didn't work but yeah
it was it was great to have to force
ourselves to try these things and
at least have these segments that were
like our bread and butter and that we
knew were going to work
we also had guests
come in we had a dedicated
effort to book guests like through
traditional means like
a booking agent that's how you get weird
al yankovic to come on the show that's
how you get in touch with jack black to
come on and sing silent night for
episode 85. we also at the end of
um that year episode 84 we
we made the christmas booty music video
to re-engage and all we had done was
announce buddy system season two none of
it came out until
season 13
january of 2018
we reduced our number of videos from
four to three
per episode
but we were continuing
to do the segment at gmm 22.
um
at the end of 2017
it was during this season that we were
releasing buddy system season two
it was all happening at the same time
yeah it's also when i started going to
therapy
yeah that was freaking crazy well you
know there's a um
uh there's a couple of other elements
too that this is not the kind of thing
that we typically think about or talk
about but
i'm sure that if we were to talk to some
of the folks who work more on the
production side of gmm
a lot of the things that we do now in
terms of the way
thumbnails are created the way that
graphics are created the way the edit
the editing workflow
the audio workflow yeah all this
back-end stuff that enables the show to
happen every single day those
efficiencies
were developed during gmm-22 that's not
something that we often think about but
anything that worked
we kept
what didn't work which mainly was doing
three or four or five videos every
single day right didn't work on a number
of levels but there's so many things
that we took forward yeah we learned how
to work with guests
and so then well i i won't get ahead of
myself because
that's the second half of gmm 22 in
january 2018
um
that's episode 12 was when we did fancy
fast food big mac
so it's like that is a staple of the
mythical kitchen channel now
we did our first munch madness
tournament which i we ultimately
we we so that was like that was pretty
pivotal yeah was it a
multi-day thing oh yeah and then episode
116 will it churro was the last gmm-22
but then the things we continued from
there were
having guests on the show
you being able to use the teleprompter
for the stuff that we just needed to get
through like
how a game works
right in the intros
so it was
there was a like you said there was a
lot of efficiencies that like when we
said okay in season 14
we're going back to one video a day and
then good mythical more and that's it
we know forever we had this capability
we were like we if we can make three or
four times this amount of content in an
episode then
then
we can shoot things more efficiently
we can start shooting more episodes in a
day
we can we can
we can have more time to work on other
things
and still keep good mythical mourning
at the couch
because one of the things that was
happening with the book and the tour and
buddy system which represented things
that we
really want to do they become more
difficult to enjoy when you just can't
really devote
time to them right
and then they everything begins to feel
a little bit like a burden like okay
gmm
when you want to work on this gmm feels
like oh that feels like a burden or when
or it's like when you're you've got gmm
scheduled to shoot and you well i need
to work on this book that begins to feel
like a burden yeah we knew that wasn't
sustainable we also knew the thing that
we didn't want to do was
stop doing anything right that's the one
thing that we've never really considered
is stopping doing anything right uh it's
just finding a more efficient way to do
it but the beautiful thing about this is
that it solved a lot of problems for us
but then
nobody like i mean i'm sure there's
somebody out there who's like
i was disappointed when you guys went
back to one episode a day i know that
that group of people exist and you know
what i love you for that
but
um i think the vast majority of people
were happy to get their good old
traditional gmm back but we had we were
able to be like hey we can actually
write this thing or do this thing oh no
we didn't do a buddy system season three
and we probably never will but hey we're
trying to do other things
and we wouldn't be able to do those if
we hadn't transitioned back season 14
episode 13 is when we did shuffleboard
so it's you know we had confidence to do
these bigger set pieces
like shuffleboard
um we also that's when we released the
gmm billboards
with the body paint well and and another
thing that is beginning to happen here
pretty uh consistently i would say that
it started not it started during
season it started a little bit during
the gmn 22 and then it settles into
itself a little bit more in season 14
is there's a thumbnail
strategy there is a face
might be your face might be my face
feeling about half the screen there's
words
on the thumbnail itself like big bold
words that's happening more
and more
often right and we had it yep
and then
we had a long streak of high performers
from episode 29 to episode 36 mre taste
test six and a half million leaving
things in nail polish six and a half
million president foods you know where
jordan was
talking for the oh we're bringing i
think we're trying to bring that format
back yeah soon and this was the season
that we launched ltat
so gmail 22 went away and then ltat
we didn't we started that let's keep
going into season 15. okay
i mean this will start getting quicker
because we're getting closer to things
that
are just new news january 2019 we had
that new
collagi intro
and we were like we're doing the rhett
and link live shows like we started in
london right it was like the concert
yeah we got hypnotized yeah you talked
about how finland doesn't exist
like what's my superhero mask
like episode 91 was hot food cold versus
cold food hot it's like getting into
some of those things that like we're
still doing now well in 2019. by the
time season 15 rolled around we were
definitely getting this
very clear message
that was hey when you guys eat weird
stuff yeah or when you guys just eat
stuff
or when you guys talk about food
it's going to get more views
and so
the game beca began or
became finding ways to incorporate food
into an episode while it's still doing
something completely original that
doesn't feel derivative
still the name of the game in a lot of
ways but as you can see we continue to
and as we continue to continue to uh try
to find things that aren't eating food
that people will get excited about yeah
and you know it's like once you get into
2019
we're
we've got 16 million subscribers we're
talking about the lost causes of bleak
creek we've got josh doing a show on
sundays
after ltat we're launching alternate
universe snacks with wheat fix
and then
we did the buoys creek series
episode 1630
and then we by the end of that year
um we had done our
bleak creek
mini tour and that was when we wrapped
up ltat and then we're we're all the way
to season 17
2020. oh day
not
launching gut check eating every ben and
jerry's flavor not knowing that kovid's
right around the corner so then we had
the home epi split screen episodes
then like slowly ramping up our ability
to produce back in the studio
to the point where by episode 1789
we've got this huge pup puck course
talking about the most expensive item at
7-eleven yeah so just
in bringing us closer to bringing us to
last year yeah it's it it's funny as i
think about the present you know okay
going from
gmm 22 well again you think about the
the the eras
and
you know that the early gmm of figuring
a bunch of stuff out
then that middle or early middle era
that we talked about with the incredible
growth and the incredible engagement
yeah the takeoff and then the thing that
i think is
i wouldn't have been able to process
is
because it you could believe like if you
if you you could think and i think maybe
some people do think this is just like
oh you guys you really screwed up when
you did when you did the gmm 22 thing
and that's why
their videos aren't getting 20 million
views or whatever but looking at the
what actually happened is there's this
incredible growth and then things sort
of settled into a place just because you
know that's just the way youtube works
there's changes that that take place and
we kind of settled into something and
then when we did gmm 22
the views actually were in the
engagement sort of went up just because
there were so many videos
but we abandoned that for all the
reasons that we've covered and then
those things if the efficiencies it was
a refining then it moved into a refining
phase which that reddit thread called a
renaissance where it was yeah it was a
reinvigoration of what we do best
and doubling down on those things
uh you know and so you might start to
get more
homogeneity
but to capitalize on the success and it
that was really working with in that
renaissance phase well one of the you
know this is the thing that we're always
up against and and i'd i'd like to spend
a little bit of time just talking about
the future of gmm like what what are the
the next 10 years of gmm if that's you
know i don't know how long we're going
to do the show but let's just say that
as we move into the second decade of gmm
yeah you know one of the things that you
definitely see and of course listen we
you know we we are very in touch with
what
long-time mythical beasts think and and
all the opinions that float around and
we we value all that we're making this
show for you
um you know
we are all so frustrated by some of the
changes that have taken place on youtube
to reward that homogeneity is that the
word
uh of of of a product and a
predictability and
things that have led us to yeah the
thumbnails pretty much feel the same
because whenever we divert from that we
get less clicks right and that's
something that you know you look at the
most engaging
youtuber on the platform and mr beast
and look at his thumbnails well he's
doing the same thing and he's doing
something different but he's doing it in
the same way he he knows that that's the
system right he's not
doing the old study which is constantly
trying something new he's like this is
what works i'm gonna keep doing it for
as long as i can yeah it's interesting
when you're making a video that's a show
that's coming out five times a week and
we're getting this feedback that this is
what people are clicking on obviously
they continue to click on things with
our food related
but
you know we don't just do this show to
just fill a gap
in our business strategy right we we
every day we think about good mythical
morning as this is still our bread and
butter yeah we want to do other things
we are doing other things
but this is still our bread and butter
this is still something that
people depend on in in a lot of ways and
enjoy it's not just some fluffy product
that we want people to just you know it
it's meaningful in people's lives it's
meaningful in our lives but but the
thing that we've been talking about
recently is as we find ourselves in this
platform where
consistency and predictability and
homogeneity are rewarded right the more
you can kind of center on a strategy on
a channel and be like this is the very
specific thing that you're getting from
this channel
and this is the very specific thing that
you're getting from this channel
we've had this sort of existential
crisis that we've been dealing with
which is well we're trying to do a
variety show we're trying to do a show
that comes out every single day and
covers a lot of different ground
but we're doing it in a place where
specificity and focus has been rewarded
more and more you know people try a
bunch of different things are not
necessarily getting rewarded they try a
bunch of and we we were actually we were
watching some tick tock videos last
night as a matter of fact i'm talking
about this phenomenon on tick tock where
you can look at somebody's channel and
be like oh this is this guy and he was
trying he's doing like seven different
characters and all of a sudden he
something clicks with one character and
then he fine tunes that character and
now every single video is that guy
and are we and my question was are we
moving into a place on the internet when
it comes to internet content where
everyone just
zeros in on the particular thing that is
working and then they it's like you've
got this uh
forgive the analogy you've got this cow
that's got uh udders
and then you're like oh everything's
coming out of this teat let's just focus
on this teat and you just and this is
what the internet does the internet
sends you to a particular teat and you
keep going back to that teat sucks the
life out of the tea and suck that tea
clean off and what we what we are
committed to doing both as as a company
as a brand with our whole suite of
content and everything we're doing and
including gmm is we want you to suck on
every teat
you know we don't want to just suck we
don't want to just give we don't want to
just keep putting one teat out there for
you to suck on sounds embarrassing but i
have to agree we've got lots of teats
and we want you to suck on all of them
to equal degrees
i think there's a there's a focus as i
think about the future i'm just thinking
about
the continuing to make sure the utter is
got lots of teats and it's not just a
one t
we have a loyal
viewership of mythical beasts that are
going to watch no matter what and what
we're realizing is that
like this presents an opportunity for us
and our and the team
to say okay we are going to determine
to
continue to experiment to assert that we
are more than just people who shove
food in our face yeah
and we need to take risks creatively and
we need to say we need to try different
things and continue the story you know
there's ebbs and flows there's like okay
we tried this thing
we're gonna and then it
maybe you say the whole thing didn't
work it's like that's not true there's
always things that carry on from
everything you try yeah and yeah even
the things that don't work lead
they
they help direct you into the future so
okay now we're gonna run interference on
this but
i think that
that's that's where we're at with gmm is
saying okay what
how does it continue to evolve
you know and it's and how do we earmark
a certain number of episodes where we're
going to
continue to push innovation and
experimentation
uh within the parameters of us being
able to
you know show up and and do it within
the con the construct of the show yeah
and this has been you know frankly uh
with the pandemic
this has been a is this a minute we've
had a great great
time during the pandemic as a company uh
our team has been incredible being able
to produce the show that we've been able
to produce
it's just phenomenal what we've been
able to do
but it's been tough it's been tough on
our team it's been tough on our our
riders especially who are isolated you
know it's like we have a production crew
that comes in
and but it's still it's still less than
what we had pre-pandemic right
and you know we don't just bring in all
the the the writers all the time because
it's just unnecessary risk at this point
but we believe that we're we're getting
towards the end of this thing and we're
going to get back to whatever our new
normal is one of the things that just
i'm just to say i'm saying this because
there's a level of excitement around the
show yeah and and i think that
as we think about
not having the restrictions of a
pandemic
getting our crew back here in this
building not yet as soon as it's safe
um i mean it's talking about everybody
back um
and really doubling down i i think i'm
just saying this to say that when i
think about the future of gmm
i even already this year like me and you
have been thinking about it and been
engaging with it in a way that you know
because we do so many other creative
things and we have such a great team
there are times where i kind of like i
don't really have to think about gmm
right now i can just be i can just show
up and be a part of the episodes in the
way that i am but i'm not i don't have
to think about
i don't have to think about the future
of it and like where are we going with
this
but right now
there's this focus on
this is something special and this we're
not going to just it's not going to just
fade off slowly
uh
and and be this thing that is just a
relic of the internet like the the focus
right now is like hey you know this is
incredible that we're we've been doing
this for a decade and there's been ups
and there's been downs we've learned a
whole lot
but we're not just trying to settle into
a comfortable
thing like we're still trying to
innovate we still will innovate we're
going to be trying
newer
bolder things this year
than we did last year
you know we've never been more focused
on that and the appreciation that i have
with the this process that i went
through looking back through all this is
that like it's a continuation of what
we've done it's like the reason why the
show has gone on so long
and will continue to go on is that
it's constantly changing
it's not it's never it's never just one
thing
and
it's most it's you most usually changes
are not drastic but they're
you know they're over the cour you know
you discover things you realize we
discovered things and then you apply
those things and so that's going to
continue to happen
so i don't anticipate
uh and a drastic change in good mythical
morning but i fully expect a continued
evolution of the show and i do sense
that we're at a juncture
where
over the course of this year
it's going to as we you know we spent
our time looking backwards over 10 years
we've done our celebration and now it's
all right
we're we're continuing to push forward
creatively in it and so that we can
define what
this show is going to look like 10 years
from now
yeah over time and like you said you
know and this is actually one of the
things that's given us this sort of i
think a new
sense of
uh
we we tend to like lots of people in
this business and lots of people in
entertainment in general and probably
just lots of people
around the world
sometimes you begin to let a little too
much fear creep into the way that you
think about things right yeah so i think
when you when you've been doing
something like this for as long as we
have and you've kind of experienced the
level of success that we have
and you've seen ups and downs anytime
there's a down
fear creeps in it's like oh okay what uh
what and then you fear doesn't lead to
innovation a lot of times for a lot of
times
for people
fear leads to
taking less risks you get scared and
you're like i don't want to go i don't
want to go into the deep end i don't
want to try that
um
and we kind of recognize that and of
course we've had the restrictions of the
pandemic which restricted the ability to
really innovate in big ways
but
because we have that the i don't know
what the number of people specifically
is but there are a number of you out
there
who like link said you watch every
single day like you're just a gmm
watcher it's part of your daily routine
or maybe you watch it all on saturday
but
through the ups and downs and the
changes you've watched the show
and you actually give us the ability
to take risks because what we found is
regardless of what we do there's a
certain number of people who are like
hey i'm showing up this is what i do i
support you guys
that knowing that and embracing that has
really given us this this confidence to
be like
man we can you really can't got nothing
to lose by really getting experimental
yeah it's a great great place to be in
to to have 10 years under our belt and
to know that we've got
that
that loyal connection
with with those mythical beasts and uh
it's it's extremely comforting and it's
it it makes this exciting and and you
know what
as much as we talk about clicks and
views and
the reason we talk and think about that
is because we're trying to support a
business here with a lot of staff
um
but
when we think about gmm
i think i speak for both of us when i
say this when we think about gmm and we
think about what we're doing and we
think about the person that we're
talking to
i'm not thinking about that person who
just clicks on a video every once in a
while i'm thinking about the person who
i'm thinking about a mythical beast yeah
you know i'm thinking about a mythical
beast who
is coming back you know when we
when we continue a dumb bit
i don't re-explain the bit like this is
your first time i just take it for
granted that this bit is for you
who've been watching you know yeah and
if you if you're if you are watching for
the first time well you'll catch up
you'll catch on you know it's like
stepping into a game after everybody
started playing it you'll figure it out
i think um
i anticipated that i would be a lot more
sentimental at celebrating 10 years of
gmat
um well i think the reason why is
because
it's not over
you know it's we're already looking
forward yeah and we i don't think we've
ever stopped looking forward so yeah
it's nice to look back and celebrate and
on gmm over this past week
to do that and it has been special but
having this overwhelming sense of i'm
not going to say we're just getting
started because that's cheesy
we're not no no we've done this for 10
years actually we're saying that at the
beginning of every episode this season
we're just getting started
but you know what i'm saying yeah i i it
ain't over so
i i did i'm not prone to get too
sentimental about something that i'm in
the middle of and very excited about and
as we look forward yeah so i'll just
leave it at that no tears yeah i mean if
the show if the show ends at some point
uh which for whatever reason it will i
mean
there's gonna be some circumstances that
lead to it ending at some point
uh i'll cry then [ __ ] right yeah [ __ ]
right here
you [ __ ] right man uh
okay i i got a quick wreck
um i've been listening to the audible
version of the book will
will smith autobiography
sing the cover um
you know
being a huge fan of
like being our age
like growing up and experiencing
like the dj jazzy jeff and the fresh
prince era as a middle schooler
and really loving music documentaries
like i loved the first
third of his book because it was about
that and so if you're
my age and you're into that stuff you'll
be into hearing
the stories behind them the making of
everything that led to like those first
two albums and then the stories of him
the story of him getting to be the fresh
prince of bel-air
uh there's some shorter stories out
there on youtube that are absolutely
amazing but hearing it
hearing him perform his book he doesn't
just read his book he performs his book
like he does impressions of every single
of so many people
and you can tell it's like these like
his grandma and jeff and
uh quincy jones and so it's really great
stories and then
i gotta say i wasn't a huge fan of will
smith the actor
i was just you know more of the musician
and and
and the uh
and fresh prince but
it was good i did i actually couldn't
have told you that like
yeah he was he was pretty much for a
long time the biggest star on the planet
like yeah it seems very obvious but like
i didn't
i didn't i wasn't a fan of his movies
but then seeing that and like
i so as a as a business owner and
leader
i enjoyed the second half of the book in
terms of like him saying okay as an
artist this is what i'm going after and
this is the team i'm surrounding myself
with and this is how we're gonna go
about it
and there's also the the um the partner
uh
aspect of like
um
you know being a husband being a dad
like all that stuff was pretty cool too
um
it's pretty inspiring a lot of fun to
listen to some really good stories in
there so uh
if if that floats your boat i highly
recommend will will the audible book
well thanks for joining us thanks for
joining us for 10 years if you're one of
those here's the 10 more yeah
gear biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]